tomaten sind somit das beste gemüse
unter dem himmel oder deswegen schnappen
werden sie jetzt mal unsere anzucht
schalen die aussaat erde das saatgut und
dann sprechen wir darüber was man
beachten muss bei der jungpflanzen
anzucht von tomaten damit man dann am
ende auch richtig schön kräftige
pflanzen ins beet oder ins gewächshaus
gepflanzt
bevor wir die samen aus packen und los
sehen möchte ich noch mal über den
zeitpunkt sprechen wann man denn mit der
tomaten an sucht anfangen sollte und da
unterscheide ich immer in die tomaten
die ins gewächshaus wandern sollen und
die tomaten die ins freiland wandern
sollen weil im gewächshaus ist natürlich
ein bisschen wärmer und da kann ich hier
bei mir in der gegend auf jeden fall je
nach wetter schon unfair ab mitte april
pflanzen draußen im freiland geht das
erst ab mitte mai deswegen ziehe ich
auch die gewächshaus tomaten schon einen
monat früher im haus vor weil die eben
auch schon früher nach draußen wandern
können das problem wenn man zu
ungeduldig ist und zu früh mit der
anzucht anfängt ist dass die pflanzen
dann wenn sie nach draußen gepflanzt
werden einfach viel zu groß sind und das
tut ihnen nicht gut wenn sie so lange im
haus warten müssen bis sie dann endlich
nach draußen wandern können dann sind
die pflanzen am ende schwächlicher als
wenn man noch ein bisschen warten um
sich noch ein bisschen geduldet auch
wenn es schwierig ist ja was sind jetzt
die richtigen zeitpunkt die gewächshaus
tomaten ziehe ich jetzt mitte februar
vor und die freundin tomaten mitte märz
das sind für meinen garten richtig gute
zeit punkte und ich wohne genau in der
mitte von deutschland deswegen glaube
ich dass die für ganz viele von euch
auch sehr gut sprechen wir als nächstes
mal wo man die pflanzen den reihen sehen
sollte da kann man auch ganz so gut
improvisieren das spart auf jeden fall
eine menge geld wenn man zb beiden
trauben in diesem plastikschalen kauft
und die dann einfach zum auszählen
verwendet das ist ganz wichtig dass die
unten löcher haben so dass das wasser
immer abfließen kann aber gerade wenn
man viele tomaten anbauen möchte und
vielleicht seine weintrauben gar nicht
mehr im laden kauft sondern im garten
erntet und deswegen auch nicht mehr
diese schwächen hat dann lohnt sich auf
jeden fall sich so ein paar außer zahlen
zu kaufen ich habe ja ganz lange so ganz
dünnwandige aus dem ganz dünnem plastik
gehabt weil die einfach viel günstiger
waren ja und das hatte aber auch seinen
preis weil die haben dann ein oder zwei
saison ausgehalten und super viel
plastik müll produziert und ich habe
früher im professionellen gemüsebau
gearbeitet und da hatten wir quick ports
und deswegen habe ich mir jetzt auch
endlich mal privat die quick potts
gegönnt und die sind auch unglaublich
teuer bei diesem super praktisch und sie
sind einfach viel hochwertiger und
dickwandige und wir haben die im
gemüsebau einfach immer jedes jahr
wieder verwendet ich kann euch gerne
meinen link unten in die video
beschreibung packen wenn ihr euch auch
holen wollt es ist der tomaten ganz
wichtig dass man auf die größe vom kopf
machte damit die genug platz haben
gerade wenn die dann später darin
zitiert werden was dass es darüber
sprechen wir gleich auch noch aber auf
jeden fall wenn ich einzel köpfchen
verwendet dann nehme ich welche die
ungefähr oben zu zehn mal zehn
zentimeter groß sind und ich kann euch
auch gern manche einblenden welche
quickport sich jetzt hier für die
tomaten nehme und da kommt dann die
anzucht erde rein da verwende ich eine
biologische und torffreie erde man kann
auch sehr gut in kompost vorziehen wenn
der gut ausgereift ist es ist aber
wichtig dass da wirklich schön reif ist
und ganz ganz fein krümelig im zweifel
den kompost gut 7 man kann den auch mit
novus erde hälfte hälfte mission es
funktioniert auch sehr gut da kann man
auch mal ein bisschen geld sparen wenn
man sich die selber an mich aber bevor
es wirklich an die aussaat geht wollt
ihr euch natürlich erstmal ein paar
sorten aussuchen oder und ihr wissen
wollt welche tomaten sollten ich richtig
gut findet dann schaut mal unten in die
video beschreibung rein da packe ich
euch ein video hin ich habe dann nämlich
immer ganz ausführlich darüber geredet
hier ist mein automaten saatgut
für sah ich habe mir drei sorten
ausgesucht für mich ist es noch arg früh
mit der anzucht deswegen mache ich noch
nicht alle gewächshaus tomaten jetzt
weil das video ja rechtzeitig für euch
online gehen muss deswegen muss ich
alles immer viel früher machen und das
ist ja du von mir gerade gelernt aber
ich selbst die anderen das tomate zucker
traube um die tomate paul robeson gebe
wandern bei mir alle ins gewächshaus und
deswegen passt das ganz gut ich sehe
jetzt in diese größeren töpfchen hier
aber 1 cm 1 cm tief ein samenkorn aus so
dass in einem topf erstmal ganz viele
pflanzen aufgehen und später bieten wie
die dann in einzelne töpfe dann also mit
einem zentimeter erde bedecken ein
bisschen an drücken und dann kommt meine
ball brause ins spiel das ist eine
anzucht brause mit der man einfach einen
sehr weichen auf einen duschraum hat
dass die erde nicht so weggespült wird
und die samen nicht überall landen und
damit bekommt die erde dann erst mal
eine schöne dusche und dann natürlich
das beschriften nicht vergessen ich habe
in den letzten jahren immer wieder
gelernt dass man auf jeden fall einen
bleistift zum beschriften verwenden
sollte und keine nendingen oder
filzstift weil der bleistift einfach
viel besser auf den schildchen hält ich
nehme hier so als spiele ich hab meine
tausender packung von denen gekauft und
da ist es auch nicht schlimm wenn man
die später mal im biet vergisst weil die
andere verrotten und da schreibe ich
dann die namen der sorte drauf und
beschriftete jedes töpfchen damit man
später auch beeinflusster wächst jetzt
sollen deine tomatenpflanzen es gerne
ganz warme haben und zwar ungefähr so 20
bis 24 grad warmen deswegen liebe ich
die töpfchen dann jetzt erstmal in
richtung heizung nicht auf die heizung
stellen weil sie dann austrocknen können
und weist auch wahrscheinlich zu warm
ist aber so in der nähe der heizungen
sind die bei mir immer ganz gut
aufgehoben und wenn sich dann die ersten
spitzen aus der erde zeigen dann ziehen
die in ein kühleres zimmer um dann sind
so 16 bis 18 grad besser bei mir waren
da die dann immer ins badezimmer das
eigentlich ganz gut passt und dann
brauchen die auch besonders viel licht
das ist immer so ein bisschen das
problem im februar und märz wenn es
draußen noch relativ dunkel ist
beziehungsweise die tage einfach sehr
kurz sind dann beleuchte ich immer mit
kunstlicht da verwende ich led-lampen
weil die nicht so einen riesigen
stromverbrauch haben und die leuchten
immer ganz bunt in unterschiedlichen
farben es sieht immer so ein bisschen
seltsam aus aber die pflanzen drauf und
eben ein besonderes lichtspektrum um gut
wachsen zu können und die lampen
leuchten genau in diesem spektrum
deswegen es ist ganz praktisch und die
lampen verlinkt ich euch auch gerne
generell in meinen videos wenn ihr
irgendetwas sucht irgendwas braucht was
ich verwende dann schaut man in die
video beschreibung unter dem video dann
habe ich da hoffentlich daran gedacht
die links einzupacken dann muss man
natürlich auch immer daran denken die
pflänzchen ab und zu zu genießen gerade
am anfang sollte die erde eigentlich
nicht austrocknen wenn die pflanzen dann
ein bisschen größer sind ist es auch gar
nicht so schlimm wenn man mal ein paar
tage nicht liest aber vertrocknen
sollten sie natürlich nicht und die
beste art zu gießen ist wenn man hier in
diese unterlage rein gehst so dass hier
immer wasser steht und das in den topf
hochgezogen werden kann und irgendwann
sind deine pflänzchen dann ein bisschen
größer also am anfang haben die immer
noch so ganz schmale keine blätter und
danach bilden sich die ersten richtigen
blätter und das ist ein zeitpunkt an dem
eine neue aufgabe an fällt dann darf
nämlich jedes tomaten pflänzchen in ein
eigenes töpfchen umziehen und war hole
ich mal meine anderen trikots und wenn
ihr ein bisschen klatsch fahren wollt
dann könnt ihr die erst mal in etwas
kleinere tröpfchen pikieren heißt dass
das heißt man hebt die pflanze nimmt die
ganz vorsichtig an den blättern sticht
in die erde lockert die so ein bisschen
und hebt die dann in ein neues töpfchen
so dass sie mit den blättern noch aus
der erde rausschauen aber der stelle ein
bisschen tiefer in der erde versenkt ist
so hat die pflanze dann mehr platz da
könnt ihr entweder
jackpots im selben format nehmen oder
andere tröpfchen wir können sie auch
direkt im solche größeren töpfchen
zitieren ich mache das gerne dass ich
sie einmal kleinere tröpfchen peak ihre
und dann nochmal in größere wenn ich die
muße dazu habe aber es funktioniert auch
wenn man sie nur einmal zitiert also da
kommt immer ein bisschen drauf an wie
viel arbeit man sich machen möchte und
beim zitieren setzt man die pflanzen
eben immer ein bisschen tiefer als im
alten topf gesessen haben weil sie dann
noch mehr wurzeln bilden können und
einfach ein bisschen kräftiger stehen
ganz wichtig der stängel von euren
kleinen tomaten babys ist ziemlich
empfindlich deswegen fast die nicht am
stängel an sondern immer an den blättern
da werden die euch sehr dankbar für sein
ja und so normalerweise nach zwei drei
wochen werden die pflanzen ein bisschen
hungriger und dann kann man zum ersten
mal dingen ich nehme da in meinen
biologischen flüssigdünger weil der sehr
schnell wirkt bei den sehr einfach zu
dosieren ist und pflanzen jahren zb die
man selber garten herrscht kann die
stinken auch ganz ordentlich das will
man im haus bei der anzucht eigentlich
vermeiden deswegen gebe ich den einfach
über das gießwasser ein doppelt so doll
verdünnten dünger wie auf der packung
steht also einfach auf die packung von
eurem biodünger schauen und dann nochmal
doppelt so viel verdienen damit die
pflanzen nicht zu viele haben die sind
ja noch klein die brauchen noch nicht so
viel aber das ist auf jeden fall ganz
gut wenn ihr ab und zu lernen über
schließt was ein kleines bisschen dem er
mit gibt so dass die armut allem
versorgt sind was sie brauchen um groß
und kräftig zu werden und wenn es dann
so weit ist und deine pflanzen ins beet
verändern sollen dann musst du eine
woche vorher mit dem abhärten beginnen
das heißt dass man die pflanzen ganz
langsam an draußen gewöhnt weil die sind
ja noch überhaupt nicht gewöhnt dass
wind wie zum beispiel oder dass es auch
mal nachts ein bisschen kälter wird und
vor allem kennen sie noch gar kein
richtiges sonnenlicht die sind ja ihr
ganzes leben lang drin gewesen wenn du
dir jetzt einfach so ins beet pflanzen
würdest und die sonne darauf knallt dann
bekommt ihr einen sonnenbrand ohne witz
das ist wirklich schlimm für die und da
können die sogar daran sterben und
deswegen müssen wir die da ganz langsam
rand führen aber es geht auch eigentlich
relativ schnell ich bin nun mal ganz
erstaunt wie schnell die pflanzen sich
doch an seine neue umgebung gewöhnen
können weil du stellst du am ersten tag
seine pflanzen vielleicht mal nach
draußen in den schatten für 12 stunden
und danach kommen sie wieder ins haus
das reicht ihnen dann schon und am
zweiten tag des two sie mal eine stunde
in die sonne dann zwei stunden den
schatten und dann kommen sie wieder und
zwar aus und am dritten tag können sie
vielleicht schon drei stunden in der
sonne bleiben und dann wieder im
schatten und dann kommen sie erst am
abend wieder ins haus und am fünften tag
können sie vielleicht sogar schon im
schatten
ganzen tag draußen stehen und dann sogar
draußen übernachten wenn es frostfrei
ist da müsst ihr natürlich darauf achten
so dass deine pflanzen am siebten tag
dann richtig gut gewappnet sind für das
wilde leben draußen hin geht da drüben
findest du meine playlist mit meinen
kompletten tomaten videos so dass du
dich schon mal für die neue saison fit
machen kannst und da unten verlinkt ich
noch mal das video mit den tomatensorten
also welche sorten tipps ich euch da an
die hand geben kann sonst geht raus und
macht die welt ein bisschen grüner und
wir sehen uns nächsten samstag um 10 für
ein neues video team